Let's go next to our caller from the eight
three to area code, who's calling today from
83 to.
Hi, my name's Drew.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Drew, what's going on?
That's basically my question is more regarding
the potential victory that we may or as Democrats,
we might actually have.
Do you think that if we end up winning in
2020, like collectively I'm talking the Senate,
the House and the presidency.
Do you think we can pull the same stuff that
Dick Cheney pulled in 2010 and basically redistrict
so that we have more control over the legislature
and basically reverse redistricting, if you
will?
Okay.
Yeah.
So very important.
So you're you're pointing out not only do
Democrats have the opportunity to take the
White House, take the Senate and maintain
or extend control in the House, we also are
in a census year, the 2020 census.
And in 2021, that census will be used for
a whole bunch of different things, including
redistricting, figuring out distribution of
funds.
The answer is yes.
And, you know, this is the there's a there
is a discussion that sometimes happens about
should the left just go low in order to keep
up with the right?
And very often, I believe the answer is no
in the sense that if we need to do the immoral
things they do to win, we're not really better.
We're just saying, hey, we're all willing
to do the same stuff because we think we're
right.
That makes us just as bad as them.
And so with a lot of these things, I'm not
for that when it comes to the census.
If Democrats have the opportunity in 2021
to do all of the things that Republicans did
after the 2010 census, then there's actually
a moral imperative to do it, because this
is not about changing the system right now.
This is how it works.
And the opportunity comes every 10 years and
very often.
Democrats have not been in power.
And I believe that when it comes to redistricting
and distribution of funds on the basis of
the census.
Yes, if we especially if we hold the White
House, if we take the White House, hold the
House and take the Senate, it is the opportunity.
It must be done and we've got to do it and
not look back.
I see that.
I like you taking the high ground.
But I've got to be honest.
I'm tired of taking the high ground when it
comes to Republicans.
I appreciate you being a little bit more a
decent person than I am.
OK.
I don't know that it's that.
I mean, I think forever.
It's interesting that you say say it that
way, because I think just everybody has a
different bar.
You know, some people would steal to feed
their family and some people would kill one
person and some people might commit genocide
to feed their family.
And it's not about good versus bad necessarily
in such moralistic terms.
But I you know, I just I do think that it's
it's sometimes a difference of circumstance
as well.
And there's no there's no necessarily right
or wrong answer.
But I appreciate the topic being brought up
and it is an important one.
Thank you very much.
OK.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.